hey youtubers is Charlie and last
night's episode of community was an
amazing love letter to fans of NBC's
Hannibal
it was also loosely based on the plot of
David Fincher's movie zodiac since there
were so many references I'm going to do
my top 5 moments then I'll do a bit of a
breakdown and then my review so let's
catch that ass crack bandit here we go
number 5
Shirley sandwiches Shirley reopened her
business but as the episode progressed
she began to profit more and more from
the chaos created by the ass crack
bandit and it was really funny to see
her get so dark she's supposed to be the
nicest one on the show so whenever she
starts to get a little evil it gets a
little bit creepy and unsettling I give
the episode major bonus points for
having her sensing that creepy Radiohead
song during the beginning it really
gives you an idea that this is gonna be
a really strange episode you should
really think of it as like a creepy 90s
murder mystery because the plot is
loosely based on that zodiac movie from
David Fincher and that takes place
during the late 90s so it's totally
appropriate that they would use weird
90s music number for Ben Folds
everything he was awesome as the creepy
botany teacher and even though we never
found out who the actual ass crack
bandit was he was definitely one of the
best candidates if he didn't catch it
there were actually a lot of songs
during the episode sung by Ben Folds I
was never actually a Ben Folds fan
during the 90s but the tone of his music
fit perfectly with the creepy tone of
the plot I feel like if you grew up in
the 90s though this episode was
something of a love letter to you a very
creepy love letter number three the
unresolved plot so they didn't catch the
ass crack bandit and normally I would be
really pissed if there was an episode
that didn't resolve itself at the end
especially if it's not a two-parter
and this episode was not a two-parter
during the plot of David Fincher's
zodiac they never actually end up
catching the Zodiac killer so the
episode was faithful to that those
titles at the beginning with the
newspaper clippings and Annie's book is
also a visual reference to that movie -
number 2 Hannibal visits community so
I'm a huge fan of the show Hannibal and
they were basically trying to imply that
the ass crack bandit was Hannibal Lecter
if you're still trying to solve the
mystery then look at the plot of red
dragon or NBC's Hannibal I do agree that
it's one of the teachers and my number
one moment
trolling Dave Matthews fans I'm talking
about the Running Dave Matthews gag the
joke is is that during the 90s everyone
was the Dave Matthews fan the band was
amazingly popular but now everyone kind
of feels like
gets lame so no one wants to admit to
liking it in public
so whenever Jeff does the hardcore fans
call him Dave line
I laughed pretty hard but if you weren't
a big fan of 90s music then the joke was
kind of lost so I did not expect this to
be everyone else's favorite moment I was
actually surprised when they gave
starburns that cat card joke during the
episode but didn't lump him in with the
other Dave Matthews lovers I always
thought that he was supposed to be the
lamest character on the show
looks like he totally dodged the Dave
Matthews bullet on another level you
could also think of this episode as
being like Ben Folds trolling Dave
Matthews even though I'm sure there are
actually friends in real life let me
know what your favorite 90s joke was in
the comments below but here's a
breakdown of some of the bigger
references number one the title
numismatics is actually the study or
collection of currency to avid is a fan
a bowl you can actually see Bryant
Fuller's Hannibal on Abed's DVR and
later Abed speaks just like Bill Graham
at the crime scene three
starburns cat video at the end is a big
Kickstarter joke a lot of dead TV shows
like Veronica Mars have funded
themselves using Kickstarter but a lot
of people complained that most
Kickstarter czar vaporware meaning that
you invest and you get nothing in return
I also think that on another level Dan
Harmon is making the joke that he's
going to use Kickstarter to fund the
community movie overall I really like
the episode I always loved one community
does a good job paying homage to other
shows and I'm a huge fan of Hannibal so
you know win win I didn't really like
Abed's will Graham but we weren't really
meant to focus on the character we're
really meant to pay attention to the
Jeff and Annie characters I don't think
that they're supposed to end up together
but this episode kind of really dealt
with their weird relationship I love the
level of the tale that the production
went to - sticking to the plot as well
as the kind of color tones in the way
that Hannibal is shot as well as the
Zodiac movie community does a really
good job of sticking with into genre
whenever they start parroting something
if you didn't catch it the Jeff and
Annie characters we're basically taken
from the Zodiac movie Jeff's character
is meant to be that Robert Downey jr.
character so I just spent a whole bunch
of time talking about Hannibal but I
haven't announced it formally but I'll
be doing Hannibal season two videos
every week whenever the show comes back
that's not till February 28th so it's
still a little ways away but be sure to
subscribe to get everything because I'm
getting really excited it's gonna be an
amazing season if you haven't seen my
community preview video for this season
I talked about all the big guest stars
that are coming on this season next week
it's going to be Waylon Goggins from
justified which is another amazing show
even though I don't do videos for it
every week they're going to be following
up with a peer
is dead storyline that surely teed up at
the end of the episode also get really
excited this Sunday there's going to be
a new trailer for Game of Thrones so
I'll be doing a special video for that
right now click here to get last week's
community video and click here to get my
top 10 predictions for Harrow this
season thank you so much watching I'll
see you guys tonight
high fives